foreign
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on chat what's going on low
tier gamer I like that name that game is
really unique low tier gamer we I mess
with that name man I mess with that name
what you guys doing
I sent out the invites people should be
showing up momentarily
um Dart Cricket he had something to do
with his um his family uh that's why we
had to delay the show a little bit he'll
be here eventually and I actually got a
surprise guest coming for you guys man I
got a surprise guest cover for you guys
see how you like that
what is going on chat I see you guys in
there appreciate everyone for coming
through
Jim Ryan coming to the show
um no Jim Ryan is definitely not coming
to the show
uh no not King
gotta gotta keep it a little bit
original man got to keep it a little bit
original can't have King in here all the
time
yeah
it's it's I'm sure it's pretty rough
over there in the PlayStation
building right now I'm pretty sure it's
pretty rough over there
shout out to the five dollar super trap
from drawing TJ dude the news last night
was crazy and it was like 11 o'clock at
night I actually made a video about it I
don't know if you guys saw it I made a
video about it
on the gaming addict Channel man you
know follow me on that I think I'm gonna
start doing more on that channel you
know I've been doing kind of the bare
minimum I'll agree with you I I have
been doing the bare minimum on that
channel but I'm really seeing like a
huge growth
recently like you know and obviously I
know it's not like
gonna be like that all the time because
anyone that does like videos you know
that that's an up and down you know uh
up and down that goes on so clearly you
know there's going to be some times
where we do good sometimes where we do
bad
uh there's my YouTube channel guys go
there and sub to me man go sub to me
I'm gonna start trying to make like
three to four videos a week I'm gonna
try no
um not
not any of those not any of those man
not any of those I I try to get people
that people don't normally see in this
community
uh Diller and them they they do they're
in a lot man they're in a lot uh any
predictions for trailers tomorrow I got
a couple ACG no uh let me ask you guys a
a
question though I'm kind of curious how
you guys will feel uh because for those
of you that's been following me from the
beginning of all time
you know I'm sure some of you have been
following me to some degree to that to
that early Parts you'll remember I used
to do a show
on the addict show called attic
Spotlight and that pretty much what the
attic Spotlight was was just breaking
down a game you know it could be a
spoiler cast it could be a game coming
out for gonna be excited about it I
think I'm going to mainly prioritize
spoiler cast because I feel like that is
better for me in general
uh because if you do spoiler cast if you
do both of them it's going to be hard to
like if I have a spoiler cast for like
let's say God of War and I had a video
building up the anticipation for God of
War there would be the same show pretty
much but one's gonna be after the game
One's Gonna Be before and for Branding
wise I think that's like a nightmare
look at my hair guys I'm losing my hair
uh so you know I I think there's a lot
of aspects to that uh what I want to do
is I want to bring back the attic
Spotlight on iop's channel on the
channel that we were doing this now
and I want to
have a perspective where we are talking
about
you know it's going to be a spoiler cast
you know I'm gonna try to get you know
people that review games like ACG you
know I'm in talks with him right now of
maybe doing a God of War One
where me ACG maybe one more person I'm
gonna try to keep it two people I'm
gonna try to keep it low on panel so we
can get in and out where we just break
down the game you know it's a spoiler
cast because I feel like there's spoiler
casts on YouTube but there there's none
that's
I don't feel like do a good job breaking
down the game
and that's why I feel like you know I
want to aim for someone like ACG to you
know try to get him to do some of the
bigger games like obviously ACG is a
busy dude he probably couldn't do a lot
of it uh but when it comes to big big
games like Starfield if he's able to uh
you know make it up to that I would
really like uh to get me and him
breaking down some of these games
because you know ACG is one of the few
people that consumes games more than I
consume games and there's not a lot of
people that can you know absorb the
amount of games like I got a lot of
respect for ACG and how he approaches
his reviews
yes this merger has been extremely Wild
man these people take him forever
what's going on they better not be in
spaces
they better not be in spaces
I don't have a relationship with skill
up like he doesn't uh I try to reach out
to him one time and he never like
responded and I'm not saying that's like
a bad thing but if you can't get a hold
of them it's kind of hard to do anything
else
what's up tylos
all right so
the surprise guest gonna be about 10
minutes but we we could sit here and
chat we could sit here and chat you know
there's a lot of things going on a lot
of things going on
um you know I'm gonna name this in the
in the the thing as a the pre-show I'm
gonna name it is the pre-show because uh
dirt is probably coming back from uh his
family activity so he'll probably be
here in the next like 10 minutes and so
should the guests too the guests will
probably be here as well
now let me switch to
the IOP account so I can get the times
because there's some people that's
really big on making sure that we do
time stamps and and part of me
understands that but then the other part
of me is like yo I feel like you know
time stamps is a luxury and as much as I
I do try to like focus and improve the
show and make it better for you guys
those timestamps could be very like
lengthy to do uh especially back before
I was doing it live now Dirk gave me the
idea of doing it live
uh so now I do it live and that makes
things a lot easier because I don't have
to go back and do it uh so what I'm
going to name this is uh
we're gonna do the timestamps when the
show starts
because I didn't really do a starting
soon screen today because uh people have
been giving me a lot of feedback on
doing starting soon screens apparently
you guys don't like it
who would have figured man the time
stamp Mafia will come for me man
they will come for me
oh The UU Hakusho shirt yeah I actually
um
I'm a big fan of anime shirts
would love to uh to be IOP resident
wrestling game expert I'm kind of
confused what you mean by that
what you mean by IOP
you don't have to explain that to me a
little bit
so I want I want to hear from the chat
you know
tell me chat
how are we feeling about this Mario how
we feeling about it I'm curious what's
going on with that I think I think it's
good I think it's gonna do good man will
you watch One Piece live action on
Netflix when it comes out absolutely not
I don't like the live action anime stuff
there's been very few live action anime
that actually works
have you guys seen the live-action anime
for Attack on Titan it's horrible it's
absolutely horrible
yamara movie gonna be good man it's
gonna be good I think we're going to
enjoy it now I'm gonna open my window
until the other ones get here because
it's it's getting a little hot so if the
traffic going in and out of uh
gonna be a problem just tell me I'll
shut the window just let it get a little
fresh air in here before I shut it
permanently before the other panel
members get here
because originally I was just gonna rock
by myself for the rest of the year give
my uh give like dirt and uh anyone else
like a little bit of breathing room uh
because they come in here and you know
they help me run this show they do a
really good job and I was like look it's
like three weeks I was like I just told
dirt I was like man
we I'll go on there do my own little
thing and I I feel like part of me needs
to get better at talking to you guys as
a solo person too because I want to do
more streams in general and I can't
always rely on people to help me run
streams so it's easier to do a solo one
so I want to get better at that in
general but I'll be better at talking to
no one because this is the hardest type
of podcasting there is is no one to
bounce back off of where you're pretty
much just talking to yourself and the
only balance you have is a chat and now
you guys are wonderful you gave good
opinions you give good stuff to talk
about but when there's no chat and you
have to bounce off of yourself is really
difficult I would say it's the single
hardest thing to do in YouTube is
bouncing off of no one
uh let me see this movie looks to be
good uh I feel you I know P how people
feel about the Mario thing but the way I
see it is he's doing a good job like
look sure Mario might not sound exactly
how you guys want him to sound
but I feel like he sounds good enough to
get the character's point across would
it be better if he sounded a little bit
more like Mario yeah but I feel like as
long as Chris Pratt or whatever his last
name is effectively plays the character
right I'm willing to overlook the fact
that his voice doesn't exactly sound
like Mario
I was just winging my whole life I just
want you now that's an issue Wayne has
definitely affected my life in very
negative ways to a point but I always
just wing it man I always just Wing him
gonna take time to get used to in the
movie movie looks good but I've been
fooled before on dope movie trailer yeah
that could literally show us the best
points of the whole movie and the rest
is just
horrible they could definitely do that
and you know these things are easy to do
like I don't think people realize
Fanboys of anything is hard to do
they're really hard to do a five dollar
Superstar from Billy addict how are you
liking the new Pokemon game so far and
where would you break this generation
compared to others all right so I am
working on a review for Pokemon I know
I've promised to you guys for like two
weeks I got sick pretty bad for a little
bit I feel a little bit better still got
a little bit of the mucus in my lungs
but I'm able to actually talk at a good
amount before I start coughing as you
can see
been here for probably going around 10
12 minutes and that's the first time
I've really called so I can I could do
that that now the question is is do I do
it after IOP Sunday I think that's
probably what I'm gonna do I have a lot
of opinions about Pokemon I I think that
as far as competitive wise this is one
of the best Pokemons they've ever done
because they've made it so much easier
to competitively play Pokemon I have
like two or three competitive Pokemon
and I have put almost zero work into it
because just doing the dance like the
the little raids so I like that but as
far as like Pokemon scarlet and violet
as a whole one of the worst games that
I've seen in uh in Pokemon and it wasn't
even just the uh the the performance
issues I feel like they lost a little
bit of what made Pokemon Pokemon like
think about Team Rocket Team Magma I
can't remember all the the little evil
organizations and all the Pokemon games
but you got team star and they're not
even really doing anything bad
like it just I felt like they sacrificed
story elements of Pokemon to make the
game open world and I'm gonna stick by
that uh now as far as like I'll go more
in depth on my review but that that's
that's a little bit of my uh opening
opening things
my headset's dying because I'm not
speaking in it or anything
it's kind of an issue
um let me think here
I I really I don't know I like sword and
shield
I liked all of them man I liked all them
cholesterol protocol I'm working on that
game as well
uh you know I'm working on midnight Suns
I played a little bit of midnight sins
this morning I'm still feeling a little
bit unsure about it but I do like a lot
of aspects of midnight Suns I just think
this year we got a lot of good games and
no great games if that makes sense to
you guys like you know I've reviewed a
lot of games like hold up let me
let me go to the IOP review tab this
year
I have and keep in mind there's probably
two to three more reviews coming before
the end of the year I got like three
weeks I'll finish these three reviews by
then because one of them is about to
come out because it's done so there's
not really an issue in terms of that but
you know we're gonna go to the playlist
and let me
let me do another screen catcher
and let me go ahead and
here do this playlist
let me Zoom this up put this back a
little bit
I got to get stuff a little bit better
in terms of um
how everything looks sometimes I feel
like I I fail you guys on that
just a little bit
they did another update like another
update
all right so here is
the
here's our playlists
and let me press f11
let me click on the chat